what do you think of when you hear cgi
and special effects the majority of us
picture epic marvel superhero battles or
the magic filled scenes of harry potter
however the truth is there's more to cgi
than just explosions there are scenes in
films like spider-man homecoming where
the cgi is so subtle it's totally
overlooked but completely alters the
movie ready to find out what scenes in
twilight you couldn't tell used cgi and
nope we aren't talking about the
infamous chuck esme all right
that's enough experimenting for one day
the visual effects team called this
moment one of the hardest cgi scenes of
spider-man homecoming but it had nothing
to do with the scenery or iron man suit
or anything you would think had some
visual effect intervention it was tony
stark's hair after this scene was filmed
it had to be reworked in editing because
they felt it should take place at a
different time of day that meant not
only changing the lighting but a lot of
other aspects getting both tony and
peter's hair to blow realistically in
the wind was a huge challenge and visual
effects supervisor lupacora said as
funny as this sounds they had to retain
the performance of their hair
it's only natural that basically the
entirety of hogwarts would be at the
tri-wizard tournament's final challenge
but filming that scene would require
having a lot of extras and a lot of room
something they didn't have access to
while filming harry potter and the
goblet of fire so they created an
illusion they filled the first few rows
of seats with actors and then placed a
green screen behind them that allowed
the editors to add in the other half of
the crowd with cgi just like magic he or
she did only send up red sparks with
their ones spider-man 2 pulled out some
major special effects for the final
moments of the film especially for 2004.
remember doc ox demise where we watch
him fall well they used motion capture
on actor alfred molina's face and
recreated him digitally surprisingly he
did no filming for those final moments
instead they added him into the scene
using cgi when he made his comeback in
spider-man no way home he also got some
digital reconstruction done they de-aged
him
before bella can even transition into a
vampire she has another ironically much
more lethal transition the filmmakers
needed to showcase how much her
pregnancy with renesme took out of her
this translated into making it look like
kristen stewart had dropped at least 30
pounds
you look terrible while prosthetics did
help them out a little it was only with
the final touches of cgi on her face and
entire body that they were able to
create what we see in breaking dawn part
one
peace
we're going to let you in on a secret
robert downey jr isn't a superhero in
real life which means he's also not
invincible for example rdj hurt his
ankle so bad on the set of iron man 3
that he was out of production for a full
six weeks but instead of halting filming
and delaying the release date marvel put
the film in the hands of the visual
effects department who were able to take
footage of an rdj body double and
digitally recreate and insert rdj's face
in post-production you know the iconic i
am iron man speech that wasn't really
rdj i'm a changed man no one could ever
guess just how successful twilight was
going to be so naturally a lot of things
changed when they got the ok to film the
rest of the saga things like a bigger
budget and a very different location for
new moon production was moved from
portland to vancouver but they had to
somehow keep the continuity between the
two films especially with the buildings
to do this they basically reconstructed
forks high using a green screen the
actors were actually just filming in an
outdoor parking lot
although the philosopher's stone was
made back in 2001 they were still able
to pull off some major cgi that you
probably didn't even notice during the
quidditch match in this film almost half
of the students on the broom were added
into the scene solely using cgi there
were no live actors for them filming
while it isn't the most perfect visual
effects we have to give them credit for
how seamlessly they added it in
scared harry
a little we've all seen enough of the
behind the scenes of spider-man to know
that tom holland does in fact wear a
physical spidey suit however a lot goes
into that suit to make it movie ready
using cgi they make sure that any seams
zippers wrinkles and creases are
invisible at all times during the film
even when he's just walking around that
way he always looks flawless although
brief captain marvel's appearance in
avengers end game was nothing short of
epic her hair blowing in that space wind
while her suit glows iconic but what if
we told you her hair wasn't actually
real yup brie larson actually wore a
head cap while filming this scene every
strand of hair we see in this moment was
digitally recreated and can we just say
wow it's just him
watching thor lose his eye in ragnarok
wasn't easy but filming with an eye
patch during infinity war was even
harder for chris hemsworth the eye patch
prop would constantly slip off his face
while filming until they decided they
would digitally add the eye patch in
using cgi luckily they didn't have to do
this for long thanks to rocket's slight
obsession with artificial body parts
what's this what's it look like
we all suspected that the black
panther's suit had some type of cgi
effect how else would it literally glow
purple however that wasn't all they used
cgi on the suit for while chadwick
boseman and his stunt doubles did wear a
physical suit a lot of visual effects
went into making sure it was seamless
and to give it its very sleek and
out-of-this-world appearance including
the facial part of the costume that was
often added in during post-production as
well
turns out it wasn't just captain
marvel's hair that needed some cgi
intervention during end game originally
captain marvel was meant to have the
same suit in both her film and end game
but when someone pointed out that all
the other heroes changed their outfits
every few years captain marvel's 25-year
run with the suit didn't seem realistic
so they enhanced brie larson's costume
to look completely different in
post-production
despite what you might have thought the
wolf of wall street included some major
digital enhancements including this
tennis court scene the scene was pieced
together using real life reference the
digital recreation of the buildings as
well as having the actors film in front
of a green screen and adding them into
the scenery in post-production it's no
comparison to an epic magical battle but
it's subtle and impressive nonetheless
les miz was given credit for being a
cinematic masterpiece and a part of this
praise came with the fact that the
actors were actually singing live while
filming this meant they were constantly
all wearing earpieces and microphones of
course it wouldn't have been realistic
or logical to have this technology
visible in the actual film this posed a
great challenge in post-production whose
job it was to use cgi to edit out all
the earpieces and microphones from each
actor have you spotted any forgotten
earpieces
the cgi used on natalie portman's hand
in the black swan is almost undetectable
and honestly extremely impressive which
is what makes it so great to reflect
natalie portman's character very
vigorous training and dedication they
used cgi to make the actresses fingers
smaller and more elongated
cgi isn't always about the explosions
and car chases but the subtle details
that we don't always notice however
without these nuances we wouldn't have
the perfections of super suits but the
idea is to not be noticed or the realism
of hair blowing in the wind which subtle
cgi moment was your favorite can you
think of any other moments you were
shocked to find out were cgi
thanks for watching
you